[Music]
so i mean you're looking at it in a
vacuum and we can't really look at
things in a vacuum we can just look at
all this data and kind of make
conclusions
we're kind of going closing and closing
and closing the gap with all the data
we're seeing but the closing of the gap
is going in the direction that it helps
not that it doesn't so i mean if you
want that to be your position that
there's not enough data i mean that's
completely fine and no no no no my
position my and i want to make it really
clear first off i think i want to
reiterate i think that you want to
improve the quality of life for
transgenders and i think you want
society to be as functional and tolerant
as possible i believe that's your
objective and that's certainly my
objective um so no my position isn't
there's not enough data i want to be
very clear because i know a lot of times
people will have people from opposing
viewpoints and sort of
feign middle ground no my position is
that there is such overwhelming data
right now uh that it's not good now what
you just said there i do agree with of
course people who are bullied people who
are mistreated people who are abused
probably have increased rates of
suicidality i think we would both agree
with that but the truth is that minority
groups in general actually have
lower suicide rates for example blacks
compared to whites i don't think anyone
here would say that black people are
less likely to be victims of hate crimes
nowhere else do you find the attempted
suicide rate in society outside of
modern transgenderism and wanting what's
best for them wanting a higher quality
of life
i don't think that pumping people with
hormones or going through sex resign
it's it's clearly not the solution
that's my my stance
here's why i want to correct you on
looking at other minorities and why that
doesn't make sense
the lgbt community is the only minority
where a lot of that transphobic abuse is
actually coming from inside their very
own family it's not just society i mean
blacks aren't giving
other black
it's
peop
rare but the the amount of abuse and
violence that you even see against lgbt
people within their own family is much
much higher and so you have to see that
in context as well um okay a couple of
things there uh i disagree i think you
see all kinds of abuse for example in
black american families let alone
fatherlessness uh and and then it would
be true across the board with you just
kind of lump it all in and we've had a
lot of gay activists in this program who
don't like the lgbtq aaip now and i'm
sure you don't like some of the parts
that are being added to the acronym as
the t they don't like the t just sort of
piggybacking on the lgb um they don't
have the same suicide rates gays and
lesbians it's not even close it's
exclusive to the transgender community
and if you look at paranoid
schizophrenics that's where you would
have a similar suicide rate you don't
see it in any other minority group
including by the way minority groups
throughout history who were woefully
abused so um i just i don't i i don't
think that holds water i want to
decrease a suicide rate but i don't
think it's because they're being
ostracized by society
well i mean also when you're looking at
the time frame of 1973 to 1988 versus
1989 to 2011 you also have to admit that
things have gotten a lot better civil
rights wise for the lgbt community so
again
you can't look at it in a vacuum and
just say american
slaves didn't have the same suicide rate
they didn't have the same kind of uh
abuse from within their family
very rarely from within their family
their own family
they didn't they often didn't know who
their family was they'd get the bull lip
every now and then from whitey in a
cotton field of missouri and uh be
fortunate that it wasn't worse than
their thing let's just just i know yes
just be clear jewelry goldstein is not
pro-slavery not endorsing either i'm
just saying that it's not a fair a
comparison that's all i'm saying okay i
think it's a very unfair comparison to
uh american slaves yeah i think they had
it much worse than transgenders in 2018.
well i i i actually would agree okay i i
i definitely agree on that uh i think
things are getting better i mean we have
more health care
so we do have it better than slaves back
then why did we get into this well i was
just saying because you were talking
about suicide rates and
again i'm using an extreme example to
make a point and it's the point is is
still made nowhere else do you see this
kind of a suicide rate and i think that
matters when you say things like and i
know you're well actually this would be
a perfect transition to the next topic
where i know i think you've you've
criticized my position when you say
let's give kids puberty blockers or
hormone replacement therapy when you say
the solution is gender reassignment
surgery and you're looking at a suicide
rate that doesn't really get better even
in the face of these wildly invasive
procedures and interventions at some
point we have to say okay maybe this
isn't the solution and because i want a
higher quality of life for transgender
people across the board
that's why i line up the way i do that's
why i think that gender dysphoria should
be treated a different way outside of
hormones injections or plastic surgery
can we acknowledge that maybe systems of
power are different than just
race gender maybe leslie jones has more
power to harass with her millions of
followers than a straight white cis male
who only has a handful
uh no abuse is about the way that people
use the platform not how many people
follow it the potential for abuse
because you've talked about comes down
to systems if somebody has hate in their
heart so yeah it doesn't matter how many
followers you have if you say hateful
things you're abusive you've talked
systemically about social media entities
needing to assist with and protect
marginalized classes correct
yes okay
so my point is this abuses of power can
be significantly more harmful with
someone who may be a black female like
let's say leslie jones and she creates a
targeted harassment campaign or take
your pick
as opposed to a straight cis white male
should that not be taken into account
equally when enforcing these rules
no the the content of the abuse should
be
assuming the content is this well no
because you're writing your article
about marginalized classes and systems
of oppression and how you have not done
enough to correct this how white males
need to do more to correct this correct
incorrect so do you think that you have
less power despite your ethnicity and
your uh gender than wesley jones because
absolutely because she has more twitter
followers
absolutely because
yes let me answer your subject let me do
the opposite of what you're doing here
on the street let me see you i don't
need you i can just go
i don't need to i can just go on twitter
we're talking about abuses of twitter
rules here josh remember this is your
article that's why
or not be able to abuse these guidelines
more effectively and more powerfully
than say my producer myself my point is
you use a disingenuous example as we've
just discussed and you look at
everything through the prism of race or
gender
you're not taking everything into
account and you want people who share
your opinions
through
the lens of race and gender i'm saying
that abuse is abuse
okay
abuse is abuse so we've just
acknowledged on the platform of twitter
that someone who would have
significantly more power on twitter
would be capable of significantly
greater abuses
no we're saying that the content of the
abuse is what matters it doesn't matter
i'm assuming the content is the same the
content is the same i'm po i'm doing the
same kind of thing a targeted harassment
campaign leslie jones is let's say uh
right
and you know that okay
music as an example
you were suggesting that it is i didn't
say she did josh so why don't you pick
an alt-right figure who's uh coordinated
one of these abuse figure uh these abuse
campaigns who has lots of flowers and
you can use them as your example
okay you pick one
no i'm saying you're the one who's who's
picking random you pick an example you
seem to have one in mind i was using
them as an example because you've
written about leslie jones so you can
all right
leslie so if you want to pick another uh
another figure
no i'm not always i don't know i don't
know absolutely does abuse i don't know
i'm not all right so you can pick one
and we could compare it and use a
hypothetical scenario take anyone you
want
so you don't know and but you're just
randomly picking random people but you
said you don't i didn't randomly pick
someone and say that she committed any
kind of abuse on twitter i was talking
about systems of power as you write
about in your article saying that as a
white male you haven't done enough to
correct this you effectively call to
action other white males to correct this
injustice online correct or incorrect am
i misrepresenting you there
yeah i think people with power should
speak up for victims and those who are
abused and you believe that someone has
more power simply because he is white
and straight online than someone who has
800 times the followers and reach and
financial uh backing
now what i'm saying is that
the content of someone's abuse is what
needs to be considered not how many
followers they have yes the content
should be considered so content being
equal let's say
alt-right person okay does the exact
same thing that i don't know leslie
jones let's say will smith i don't know
if he's on twitter i'm trying to take
any minority here i'm not attributing it
to any specific minority maybe he's not
on twitter i have no idea about minority
maybe you just pick two white people one
with more followers
it's your example where you call on
people to fix these systems of
oppression you specifically call on
facebook twitter and white male writers
to rectify the situation that's what you
write about based on race your entire
article is written through the prism of
race and what i'm saying is when you're
watching yes you read race into
everything apparently uh but yeah i
agree white have you not written let's
stand up for those who are abused okay
you don't see that you don't see that as
a statement based entirely on race
do you agree that the
white men who are some of the most
powerful people in the world the people
who are naturally advantaged by the
current injustice systems you think that
i i just don't understand
you don't think that they should stand
up for victims no i think everybody
should
right but should white men stand up for
victims they would be included amongst
everybody
yeah but do you think that they might
have outsized
responsibility because they have
outsized power
no i just based it on the content
right exactly so so we both agreed then
then what matters is based on the
content you just brought up so why would
white men could not be less relevant
that's my point we agree
whether it's a white man or a black
female
the abuse is the abuse and the abuse of
power can be more powerful if this
person has a much greater platform and
my point is your call to action as you
just did now i'm glad that we've
clarified is to white men to correct
these institutional forms of
discrimination and that is the
presupposition of your new rules and
guidelines when dictating what speech is
and is not allowed and it doesn't take
into account white men do need to stand
up for victims of abuse right how about
good men
uh yeah all good men so why did you lead
with victims of abuse why not good men
do you not consider yourself they are
the ones who are unnaturally privileged
in this system and so they need to be
they need to be the ones willing to
stand up whether it's sexual assault and
harassment whether it's online abuse
white men who control a lot of things in
this world do need to stand up and stand
with victims that seems pretty
reasonable you know it's the same way
that you know major politicians who hold
power in countries around the world need
to stand up for victims of abuse and for
human rights
okay so would you believe when barack
obama was president that this man was
more powerful than say the white man
tilling the cornfields
um i'm not sure about your what i would
say is that the president is more
powerful than an average citizen yes
a black president
again because you said white men need to
fix this problem
i said how about good men right a black
president barack obama would he or and
you just use politicians as an example
i'm following your logic we're serving
the common values but he sure did
whereas what most white men have not or
a lot of white men have not stood there
against
[Music]
this is what you've written about in
your article correct yeah yes and you
don't see that as being written through
the prism of race
no i'm i'm okay saying that white men
good that's fine
i think that saying white men
specifically and only seeing systems of
power uh through the prism of race is
seeing it through the prism of race you
don't so perfect world here what you're
trying to do is a race race as if it's
not a problem in this country and that's
just ridiculously false no i didn't do
it so if you really think that everyone
is already treated equally and so
everyone should stand up equally for
abuse then you clearly have a misguided
view of the world you don't think that
everyone should equally stand up in the
face of abuse sure do but i sure don't
think that everyone is equally
privileged to stand up and that's why
those with more power i don't believe
everyone is equally privileged on that
we agree i simply don't see privilege
exclusively through the lenses of race
and gender my point is there are people
who can be abused on these social media
platforms simply for having unpopular
views regardless of whether white black
gay straight trans male female that's my
point it happens every day and you see
that all the time unpopular viewpoints
it's a pendulum that swings for example
you know right now yours would be less
popular amongst many people in the tech
community or people with social media
who would advocate for more open
platforms i think your views shouldn't
be censored to use your words i think
you should be as free to express it as i
am and i would like to see rules from
facebook and twitter and i would
absolutely even if you even if you at
replied me a thousand times a day which
would likely be a violation of their
guidelines i would defend your right to
do it you're the one advocating the
opposite and you're advocating the
opposite through your article again
exclusively through the prism of race
and gender
you're right i'm advocating against
abuse you nailed it
yes
yes you're advocating against abuse and
attributing abuse exclusively to uh
people of a given race or gender and a
system of classes you just asked for
that yeah we're not going to repeat this
let's let's go backwards
closing thoughts what happens in
facebook twitter youtube and your
perfect world what happens right now
what is youtube for example missing
uh my article was about facebook and
twitter what is facebook and twitter
complicated problems
um facebook needs to create
policies that understand where privilege
lies and does not protect people
or does not allow abuse of certain races
just because there's a modifier like age
attached to them yeah and twitter needs
to create better rules to prevent abuse
through the reply system sure yeah
you write for a major publication like
techcrunch and uh we're an independent
outlet so i would love to see you go on
your own and see where the privilege
lies that's my point we just need to let
free speech be free speech for all
regardless of race gender orientation
then it becomes a really simple simple
issue may sound reductive hey maybe it
is either free speech
it sounds like it means that people who
are abused don't need any special help
yeah i know when you hear it that way if
you hear the ears of race
um you don't believe the second
amendment is for all people to protect
against i want to make i said that i
want to make clear that's why i said i
want to make clear i'm asking what do
you believe the second amendment is for
then
i think the second amendment was written
at a time when we were worried about
being attacked by other major nations we
were a brand new nation starting out we
didn't have a lot to defend ourselves
and the second amendment was written so
that everybody everybody had a weapon in
case england came back in case spain
tried to invade us that's why it was
written so it wasn't written so the fact
there would be no proof of the founding
fathers admitting that even they
themselves could become tyrannical and
it was written to protect the people
from even them like george washington
hypotheticals now no i'm saying this
these are actual quotes i have them up
with spider.com okay let me see are you
denying you know i'm not gonna interrupt
you anymore uh okay then let me know let
me finish yeah these are actual quotes
from the founding fathers they said of
course it is for the entire people and
no government will disarm its own people
the people have the right to protect
themselves against even us the
government these are quotes from george
washington george mason thomas jefferson
madison right so they made sure it
wasn't well you just said about england
it was about the united states
government as well george washington
fascinating character was about england
and i said you think attackers you said
it was written because they thought of
outside threats
spain england i said no it was written
and they specifically wrote that it was
also for domestic threats including
themselves so your only defense on 32
000 americans dead is the second
amendment and something that was written
200 years ago no i'm asking i'm asking
because that's all you're saying
no i've also said that i don't believe
that your proposal would decrease gun
crime
and you just lied about the second
amendment no i did not lie about it i
didn't you said i was writing our time
for outside threats in spain and england
and i just gave you examples of how it
was written for domestic tyranny
including by george washington jefferson
madison mason adams they said it could
be us that's why you all need to be
armed so it wasn't written for foreign
entities it was written for the united
states
uh uh yes but it no it wasn't originally
no that one actually wasn't it was
actually
for a tyrannical government like england
no do you we have a tournament it didn't
say like england just like you said what
does it say
do you think we have a tyrannical
government no that's again we've already
answered that question could it be
potentially absolutely
any government can become tyrannical yes
absolutely okay this argument by the way
it would have to be our military we have
to take our guns uh ain't gonna happen
civilian military families wouldn't
happen why do you think it wouldn't
happen and let's say if they were
tyrannical what do you think it wouldn't
happen
because i know the military families
i've actually went to iraq twice and i
will tell you one thing there's not a
chance
oh it is an argument i have a colonel i
have so i have the reason they can't is
because of an entirely armed populace
that's why they can't take away
everyone's gun so you're saying that our
military if we weren't armed would turn
on us
okay got it no so moving well that's
what you just said
yeah you didn't say it but actually
you're you're alluding to that but
you're you're alluding to that but okay
let me finish
didn't you just talk about former
military who shot
five in dallas
uh my
father-in-law was an army colonel and
this
is
about former military shots when in
dallas so there are some people who
would be willing to do it right not all
but some shot cops oh are you are you
bringing up a psychopath that actually
are you bringing up a psychopathy
saying you've no military listen
i've entertained the troops as well i've
gone over to guantanamo bay i've done
the tours
shooter in dallas what a psychopath are
you serious is that the first time i
bring up military you compare so you're
comparing all our military plus mike
no i'm not
bombs no i'm not
then why would you bring that up first
because you said i know people who
wouldn't do it i know people who would i
don't one of our military would do it he
wasn't in the military he had people the
reason there is no possibility of that
is because of the second amendment
it's amazing how hard you have to
backpedal to fight your argument but let
me finish this
i didn't backpedal anything
or something i want to be for something
we can agree on something i believe
americans should have guns i believe
it's in our dna i believe it goes back
to the beginning of our country and i
believe to get rid of them not only
would be uh untenable but impossible
so here's what i'll say
so we put together uh
a gun registry everybody has guns yeah
i'm gonna go against it but go i got i
got it i know i got it i got it but
here's the thing
32
000 americans dead what are you willing
to do to keep your guns and stop that
what are you yeah okay i'm i'm willing
to do
be finished please let me finish well i
thought you just asked me a question
that's why i didn't interrupt you ask a
question go ahead it's it's just put it
rhetorical just leave it rhetorical okay
so trying to make it sure
i'm gonna talk for a minute then you can
talk and i appreciate the time you're
giving me i gotta tell you man i really
appreciate this i hate that i'm yelling
you know what i hate more than anything
i hate being part of the din
of the uh of left and right or whatever
because i'm not left i'm an independent
100 percent i've got my cars do more
damage to the ozone than than anything i
own so uh so let me finish
so here's what i'm saying we get uh to
stop the 32 000 dead and to stop crazy
people from getting guns like my mother
like the guy in dallas like jared
loughner like all these people we have
some serious common sense gun rules in
place number one federal registry i know
you don't like it but whatever i got it
that's what
it's not common sense that's the point
you can't say it's common sense if
there's a valid argument against it go
ahead no it is common sense 100 deadly
weapons should be registered cars are
registered everyone brings up the car
gun argument cars are registered cars
not a constitutional right and a car
actually is far more dangerous than a
than a gun and actually is more
dangerous actively you cannot have a gun
and use it you cannot have a car and use
it passively i can have a gun at my hip
to use your term and um to use your
example if i do have a gun in the studio
and it's passive it is a threat to no
one i cannot drive from point a to point
b without putting other people at risk
cars are much more dangerous no billions
of miles done every week on the roads
three feet apart from going to an 80
miles an hour totally passive so anyway
moving on no that's not true
that is true it's not a past it's not a
passive endeavor is my point someone is
inherently at risk when you are driving
on a freeway that's why there are far
more car fatalities no one is at risk
for a firearm resting on my hip no one
else is at greater risk but they are if
i'm driving on the road period that's
come on we'll both acknowledge that
let's find that common ground oh we
don't we don't acknowledge that actually
statistically
makes you 60 more likely to get shot or
shoot somebody near you that's how it is
so moving on
okay what are the chances of hurting
someone if you drive a vehicle or
getting into a vehicle crash
i've been driving for
40 years and i'm i don't i mean anybody
but what we acknowledge that probably
more than 60 percent driving but you're
not even hurting somebody not even close
if you compare miles i'm against the
registry but here's my point you don't
get to say common sense
but here's the point here's the point
here's white matters here's what matters
real quick and then i'll let you finish
this is very important this is very
important chris if we want to find
common ground genuinely okay
when you say i don't want to be yelling
i don't want to be i don't want to be a
part of this okay but part of the in
part of the rest of the idiots that yell
back and forth like we've been doing
when you say that
right respectfully
there is no way to have a dialogue when
you say
everyone should support these common
sense uh measures and if it's because if
people don't okay well if you say common
sense what that implies well let me say
it implies that someone else doesn't
have any common sense if they oppose it
when you call someone a [ __ ] when you
come on
when you when you you say someone's
running and ducking words you know as
well as i that they're scheduling issues
when you say you're going to make
someone cry the point is you if you want
to have a discussion
these aren't steps that are taken and in
this thing you're the only one who's
been yelling but go ahead and finish
your point
the statistic that people like to bring
up a lot when discussing male privilege
is the pay gap which i know is something
that a lot of conservatives claim is not
a true thing but it was the department
of labor i believe here i have it right
in front of me here the department of
labor um put out
that statistic that said 78 um cents of
every dollar is what women make
um
more they make that compared to men and
the numbers degrade
when you talk about women of color
um
hispanic women black women they make
less than that i know you said we can
argue about stats who are blue in the
face so i don't i don't want to take
mine i think i think it was the
department of justice by the way um but
i'll take yours because obviously
let people know there's nothing nothing
up my sleeves i'm not i didn't feed you
that stat um totally you're talking
about uh right now the 78 peg apple can
you said it
degrades if you go to women of color now
let me take your stat because you said
okay it gets even wider if you take
women of color how does that gap narrow
why have virtually all reputable
economists said that it's a
myth
because you just accounted for variables
very very intelligently that women of
color when you add different variables
you know that pay get maybe 68
but that pay gap becomes four percent
two percent zero percent sometimes a
plus one or two percent for women
when what
are you talking about different
industries nope not even just that see
that stat that you're talking about
simply takes the average income
of full-time working women versus men
now when you take into account not only
industry but more specifically
job more specifically hours worked
travel how long they've been in that
position that gap
disappears as a matter of fact there are
new studies coming out particularly in
science and tech engineering stem where
women make more they're certainly
admitted at vastly higher rates because
women choose not to go into those fields
so we now have provided incentives for
them too where they actually make as
much as men so you can't use stats one
way and say well and then that gap
widens if they're black and then that
gap widens if they're hold on a second
that gap narrows if they're both in the
medical field that gap is now
non-existent if the female and male are
both doctors working the same hours in
the same state there is no gap
sure but you could all there are also
statistics that show that women are
promoted less because employers are
afraid that they're going to get
pregnant and that they're not going to
stick around for all that often
um
they're not given raises at mo at
the same pace that men tend to be do
women do women get pregnant more often
than men
yeah but that's not something that
should be held against us because it
cuts both ways women are
you know told
i'm sorry but i it's it's not something
that should factor into whether or not i
get a promotion about whether i may be
pregnant down the line how much money
you will cost or make the company
should not be factored into
how much money i pay you
you can
god forbid get sick
and have to
take a long leave of absence from your
company should that be factored it is
not a statistical 50 50 likelihood
sometimes more when you get over the age
of 30 that i'm going to get sick it is a
statistical likelihood that most women
this is where feminists disconnect from
most women want to make babies most
women want to have babies and so women
end up leaving the workforce for at
least nine months i would
i would argue against that that is an
opinion that most women want to have
babies i think that society puts a lot
of pressure on more than men
more than men more than men 100
because women are
we are damned if we do damned if we
don't if we decide that we want to have
babies you just said we're going to be
costing the company more so we are not
getting raises at as often if we choose
not to have female
not to have
um
children we are as i think it was who
was that senator here i have it written
down it was that um
um cortland psych said that he did not
want his daughters to be career-obsessed
banshees so that is an example of the
idea of what women are if we choose not
to have children and we choose to pursue
a career we are career obsessive do you
think do you think that's
exclusive
do you think that's exclusive to women
you think it's exclusive of women that
people hate their bosses
no i don't think it's exclusive to women
and again
you talked about this banshees yeah i
think that's actually i think that's a
pretty funny example i'd probably
describe a lot of bosses who i had
including some at fox news as banshees
men or women screeching banshees not big
fans of them but the point is i think
you just said damned if you do damned if
you don't i just heard that women had a
choice guess what a man has
damned if you do and guess what do
because we don't get to have babies we
don't get leave there isn't maternity
leave and i know you can point to
examples like sweden in places where men
do a paternity leave and they don't
contribute anything other than
occasionally a new form of birth control
every century but we're talking about
here in the united states of america i
certainly would not consider that people
should have fraternity leave i think
that you 100 if you and your wife decide
to have children you should have
paternity leave go for it that is well i
guess it's a good thing that the white
men in power voted for maternity leave
and nine months off and nothing for us
so you can thank them for that that is
that is something that i completely
think that is wrong it's wrong and i
think that it goes back to
the fact that women
you know again i'm i'm giving you the
example that patriarchal like
traditional patriarchal mindsets affect
you too you should 100 percent get nine
months off for
if you decide to have a job and let me
say this while we're getting personal
you should 100 if you date a man who
wants nine months off leave him okay
that's not the guy you want providing
for you uh no i wouldn't do it and i
don't know any man who would who would
want to do it it'd be nice to get a few
weeks off you know maybe go down to
kauai have a luau that'd be fun nine
months off no um but let me uh i i
certainly i think you went to the worst
example right off the bat and i think
you'll see that most people don't agree
with you on that so let's go down the
list to other examples because certainly
i think you would concede we would both
agree there is an economic argument to
be made there uh as to why we're just
talking bottom line dollars and cents
with pregnancy that's not indicative of
period overall females in the workforce
versus men so let's remove pregnancy
from the table
listen to me well you just said men and
women cannot agree my wife and i agree
and every woman on this so men and women
can agree you and i don't but all right
i'm sorry that was reductive okay
a fetus is both
a separate being and part of your body
and you you if you've never experienced
it you cannot understand that it is
it is not
separate from your body it isn't and if
it's not the right time for you to have
a baby and if you lived in a humane
society where you could terminate that
pregnancy before it's really a fetus i
you know there are many many
circumstances in which that that you you
know women have to be free to make that
choice it doesn't live on in a spaceship
it doesn't live without you know using
the mother's body as
as its environment as its host this is
something we have to grapple with well
then why does day 40 matter at all
sorry then why does this is why i say
that your i understand your middle
ground is a more intellectually i
believe untenable position than even the
most radical feminist who believes until
it comes out of the womb if you use the
argument that it is a part of your body
it is not a separate life it is not a
separate being also a separate life and
it's a part of your body it's an end and
sentence then what matters with day 40.
i don't this is the logic
why is there a cut off then
because you're at you know i'm i'm
trying to be really honest with you
you're asking for a black and white
answer for me and i don't have one what
i'm saying is you know in my 55 years on
the planet having had two children
having traveled all over the world
having seen many many
women's lives who were
ruined and babies lives who were ruined
by women not being able to control their
reproduction i've lost you and
that's okay
yes i can hear you don't stress you can
just hit the button to resend us video
it's uh this is what happens with with
phones in big cities i blame big a t and
t
sorry about that um and you know and
having thought deeply about this issue
we're not going to have a an
intellectually pure
solution for any policies because there
aren't any but what we are going to have
is humane policies that take into
account uh women's and babies needs and
in my view a humane society makes
contraception readily available uh gives
women access to abortion if they need it
and the morning after pill in the first
trimester um and uh and you know makes
adoption really easy and and and
supports all children
make sure there's food and
education and clothing for all children
so that you know more women would not
need to choose abortion i'm with the
pro-lifers on that and i'm with the
pro-choicers on women really needing to
control their bodies at least for the
first um trimester where i don't know
how to get you back but oh that well i i
just hit if you there's a little video
icon i believe
jared you can help her tell her that it
is a little video icon
little blue video icon um i'm sure you
can imagine where i would disagree with
you not as a man
but
intellectually along the trail of
there's nothing humane
if there we go
uh there's nothing humane if it's a life
and that's why i was so interested in
your essay when you said it is about
societies where men control women's
reproduction from this no no no no see
you keep going back to the male 1 and
control a woman there are plenty of
women half who agree with this position
that it is a life there is nothing
humane about ending another life that is
not your own the only question that
matters and this is one that i think
naomi especially if you're talking about
a platform where you want to bring
people together you have no chance of
convincing someone who is pro-life and
certainly no chance of convincing the
radical feminists left today if you
cannot answer the question
as to whether it is a life or not and
that's again why where i posit the only
consistent line of logic
is conception otherwise there's no
difference at day 39 day 40 um or
exiting the womb there's no difference
so so
i i i'm glad you you brought this up i
i'm i'm gonna be a good daughter before
mother's day my mom is waiting for me to
go join her i'm out here visiting my
parents so i need to hop off but i will
wrap up you know or respond to what you
just said uh you are absolutely right
that i cannot and will not give you a
black and white answer on this and
that's because i have a sense of
integrity um and from my lived
experience as a woman and as a mother as
a woman i cannot
that's not
this identity positive keep bringing as
a woman a sense of integrity okay how
about this if you don't have an answer
right tonight if you were driving home
and you thought there were a dog on the
road but you weren't quite sure and you
could slow down you wouldn't kill the
dog it's not about you it's about the
dog at that point if you don't have an
answer then you can err on the side of
not ending a life i think that's
something i think that's
the day after conception
is is a dog i mean i don't think these
are apples and oranges they're not the
same thing and i'm a very you know i
have a religious faith i have reverence
for all life i do not believe they are
the same i think that as the being
develops and matures it becomes much
more serious morally and these are deep
deep issues but it's because they're
deep issues i don't think they should be
reduced to sound bites i don't i don't
you should be reduced to sound bites
either but i don't think they should be
reduced to policies you just list it off
by the way completely anti-libertarian
about 12 that i counted policies which
involved my direct subsidization of
someone else's opinion despite the fact
that there's no answer there so if we
don't have an answer the libertarian and
both of us common ground would have to
say well we can't spend money on
somebody else's answer or opinion and of
course we would have to err on the side
of life if we don't have an answer on
the side of liberty and let women make
that choice for themselves
no not if we're talking about a
different different body a different
body with different dna different
fingers toes eyes ears central nervous
system lots of life that's a very
important argument until it's born it is
in the woman's body well there you go so
up until the womb
but i know you have to go thank you so
much naomi wolfe it is i also want to
see the platform is for everybody it's
not about pro-life pro choices yes let
me let's get that website again one more
time
sure it's daily cloud.io so come on we'd
love to have you as a guest on our
platform 100 thank you so much naomi i
appreciate it and uh i will continue
wrapping up uh here without you because
i know i know i appreciate being good
for mother's day
wow that video clip was something else
isn't that right dave i enjoyed it
thoroughly yeah it was uh clipped from
the live show every monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern that's the
best way you can just tune in watch and
uh you know comment with us live if you
want to support this content because
no one else is going to crowdershop.com
hit the like share more importantly
buy a shirt
because there are some people
who will be lucky to have shirts
in china they're starving